Hi, Mystery Recapped here. Today, I’m
going to explain an Australian science
fiction film called “2067.” Spoilers
ahead! Watch out and take care!
The premise of the movie is set in 2067, when the
world has been destroyed beyond rehabilitation
because of climate change. All plant life has been
extinct. With the lack of plant life, the amount
of oxygen in the air has decreased exponentially.
People have to buy artificial oxygen to survive.
Ninety-nine percent of the world has gone dark.
People suffocate to death. In such conditions,
only one city in Australia has survived, and it
is all thanks to a company called the Chronicorp
corporation that manufactures synthetic oxygen.
However, artificial oxygen causes a fatal disease
called ‘the sickness’ over time. Humankind has
mere years before it goes fully extinct.
Ethan Whyte is a resident of the
Australian city. He and his friend,
Jude, work as mechanics in the Chronicorp
corporation. The corporation is also working
day and night to find a cure for ‘the sickness’
and a way to save the world. Ethan’s wife, Xanthe,
also has the sickness. Ethan works hard day
and night to earn, and buy her better oxygen.
One day, as Ethan and Jude work in the tunnel,
the Chronicorp’s CTO of particle research,
Regina Jackson, summons them to her office.
There, she introduces herself to the two,
and tells them that humanity is going to die
in a few years if the conditions do not change.
She then reveals that Ethan is the only one
who can help everyone and save humanity.
Ethan is confused and doesn’t believe her.
But Regina insists he visit their lab.
The lab has huge machinery. The lab doctor named
Billy Mitchell introduces himself to Ethan,
and looks at Ethan’s wrist device for a second.
They then explain to him that Ethan’s father,
Dr Richard Whyte, started
this project twenty years ago.
The machine that stands in front of them
is a time machine called the Chronicle.
In the first-ever experiment done with the
machine, they had to send radio waves into it
to check what was on the other side. They found
out through it that 407 years later, in 2474,
the earth would have enough vegetation to maintain
enough oxygen in the air and sustain human life.
The people come to believe that if humanity
still exists several hundred years later,
it is likely that they have found solutions
to all the problems plaguing their reality.
However, a strange activity baffled the scientists
there. The waves they sent had come back reformed.
When they decoded it, they found out that someone
from the future had sent them the message saying,
“Send Ethan Whyte”.
So now, Regina and the
whole team want to send Ethan into the
future for him to bring back the cure.
Ethan is beyond surprised. He doesn’t believe
them and thinks that Regina is just bluffing.
Moreover, he doesn’t want to leave his sick wife
and go into the future. So, he declines to help.
Later Ethan and Jude are at a diner, where they
buy crisp oxygen. Jude tries to persuade Ethan to
go through with the plan and help save humanity.
However, Ethan laughs at him, saying that he
doesn’t want to be like his father. Ethan hates
his father for never being there for him.
20 years ago, his father left home and went
missing, while his mother was killed when he
was a kid. Since then, he has been brought
up by Jude, a man whom Ethan regards as his
older brother as well as a best friend.
He blames him for leaving his mother to
complete the project, and doesn’t want to follow
in his path and leave his sick wife. However, Jude
manages to persuade him, saying that the only way
he can save his wife is by finding a cure. Ethan
reminisces of his eighth birthday when his father
has bought him a strange box as a gift. As he puts
his hands inside the box, a device latches onto
his wrist, making him bleed. Richard had placed a
permanent hand device on his son. It has been many
years but Ethan doesn’t know its use yet. Later at
home, Ethan tells Xanthe everything that happened
during the day, and she too insists him to go.
The following morning, Ethan scribes, “I will
find my way back to you” on a metal flower,
and leaves it beside Xanthe. He then goes to
Regina’s office again and tells her that if he
can find only one cure, they will have to give it
first to Xanthe. Regina accepts, and takes him to
the lab again. Dr Mitchell shows him the suit that
he has to wear before getting into the machine.
As they begin to explain the mission to him,
Ethan realizes that they do not have a plan.
They have no clue what he will see,
or who he will meet at the other end.
However, after they put him in the suit, they
give him an AI device called the Archie. Archie
will show the lab Ethan's vitals at all times.
It will also help to navigate his location. Then,
they finally throw him into the machine. Inside,
Ethan moves at high speed through time. He falls
from the sky and lands in an unknown jungle.
The friction from the air causes his suit to catch
fire, so he quickly gets out of it. Then, he looks
around, and is astounded by the beauty of nature.
He finds that the world has completely changed.
The trees and the natural oxygen are back.
He walks in the direction Archie directs him, and
sees a bunker door of some sort. But what catches
his eyes is a skeleton that lies right in front
of the door. Its skull has a bullet hole in it.
Furthermore, he looks at the name tag on it and
is horrified to see his own name. The skeleton is
Ethan’s. Ethan also finds the skeleton’s Archie,
and plays the last recording on it. He hears a
man say that this is the only way, and shoots
Ethan. Just then, the device’s power goes off.
He is horrified, believing that this is the fate
that awaits him. Then, he notices the skeleton’s
wrist device. It is identical to Ethan’s, except
the light glows green in the skeleton’s device,
but Ethan’s has been red his whole life.
That night, he lights a fire and eats wild
berries. It turns out that the berries
were poisonous. Ethan vomits and starts to
go unconscious. Ethan wakes up after a while,
and is surprised to see Jude in front of him.
As it turns out, the lab saw Ethan’s vitals
dropping and assumed he was having a reaction
to poison. So, they quickly sent Jude to
the future, with the cure to save him.
Sometime later, Ethan and Jude find
that his skeleton remains there,
which means his fate hasn’t changed. They
then use Archie to find another door.
Some device scans Ethan’s eye and grants them
access. When they go in, a monitor welcomes him.
It asks him for a DNA sample. When he accepts
it, his wrist device begins to work, making
him bleed. After the blood test, it goes green.
The lights to the room turn on and they realize
that they are in Chronicorp’s lab, 407 years
later. The time machine is in front of them too.
Jude gets excited because now they have the means
to go back to the past, but Ethan doesn't think
so, saying they haven’t changed anything, and he
will end up dead; just like the dead Ethan.
Ethan checks the system log and finds a
holographic recording made by his father,
who explains that the time machine was
originally designed to collect the oxygen
data in the future planet, and then transmit
it back to the past. However, when his father
first started the time machine, he received a
message asking him to send his son to the future.
Despite his misgivings, he chose to do so and
made a DNA verification here for Ethan.
Soon, Ethan and Jude realize that the time
machine won't be able to take them back
because its battery has almost depleted after
407 years. What's worse is that the activation
of the lab triggers a malfunction in its nuclear
power core, threatening to unleash a nuclear
explosion in just four hours. This means they
have to find a way to fix the time machine and
travel back before the explosion. Running out
of time, they have to act quickly. Outside,
they are surprised to find a ruined city covered
with green plants ,but inhabited with no humans,
showing that earth starts to recover itself after
human extinction. Human skeletons are scattered
everywhere. Ethan gets to his wife's house, only
to find her bones, making him fall into despair.
Jude tries to persuade him to go back to
the past, as the cure against the sickness
doesn't seem to exist even in the future world.
However, Jude’s words make Ethan suspicious.
He then turns on the rusty Archie to play the
recording once again, from which he recognizes
Jude's voice and it seems Jude is exactly the
one who shot him. Jude raises his gun at Ethan,
strongly denying that he would shoot ethan. Ethan
finally decides to complete the mission first,
so with joint efforts, they manage to repair
the power core and then return to the lab.
Now the chronicle system works and they should
be able to return to the past; they just need
to wait 37 minutes till portal launch. Once
the countdown reaches zero, the portal will
tether to 2067 for approximately 30 seconds.
However, Ethan still finds his body remains behind
a door at the same location, which implies that
they haven't made any changes to the future.
In order to figure out the truth, Ethan pulls out
the battery of his current Archie and puts it onto
the rusty one. In that way, he gets access to
another video, in which Ethan is assured that
his future self will be killed by Jude. Jude then
confesses that there is no hope of changing the
future and he is trying to protect Ethan. Finding
it hard to believe, Ethan locks his brother up in
a room, then plays back his father's holographic
log from the day he died. He soon discovers a
conversation between the Chronicorp’s CTO,
Regina Jackson, and his father. It's shown
that Ethan's father wanted to use the time
machine to save all mankind by finding the cure,
but the CTO only intended to use the machine to
flee from the dying time with some chosen few.
However, whichever plan they choose,
someone must travel into the future and
turn on the time machine; to safely
send living matter through time,
it requires an operational link from both sides
In order to stop the CTO with her plan, his father
locks the time machine and sets Ethan's DNA as
the verification key. In anger at what Ethan's
father just did, the CTO killed him immediately.
She then orders Jude to kill Ethan’s mother and
be a guardian to him, so one day they can use
Ethan’s wristband to get access to the future.
Ethan is beyond surprised. The
man he thought of as his brother,
turned out to be the one who killed his mother
and is about to kill him too. He also realizes
that he has misunderstood his father, who
didn't deliberately abandon the family.
Knowing that Regina wants to bring
a chosen few into the future,
Ethan tries to shut the time machine down, but
Jude rushes to stop Ethan and reveals that he's
tasked here by the CTO to ensure that Ethan
is sent in time to repair the power failure.
Once Ethan activates the time
machine, he should kill Ethan.
However, Jude has formed close emotional
relations with Ethan over the years.
Seeing his brother-like friend in that state
because of him, he is guilt-ridden. So, instead
of shooting Ethan, he shoots himself dead.
In rage and regret, Ethan is determined to
fulfil his father's dying wish, which is to
find the cure and save the dying humans.
He looks into the monitor, and finds the
very first message written by his father.
He deduces that the message “Send
Ethan Whyte” was sent by himself.
Hence, he codes in the message again and sends it
into the past, along with many other things.
Meanwhile, in the laboratory of the year
2067, the CTO with a group of privileged
chosen people are waiting anxiously for
the time machine to be activated.
To their shock, however, the time machine sends
back hundreds of extinct plants along with a copy
of the recorded murder of Ethan's father. Soon
after, the time machine is destroyed by Ethan,
resulting in the collapse of the CTO's plan. In
the end, the CTO is arrested due to the murder.
The plants sent back to 2067 are cultivated to
revitalize the planet. Ethan's wife also receives
a flower sent from him and understands his choice.
While Ethan has to stay in the future world alone,
he buries Jude and forgives him. A butterfly
catches his attention, and leads him again to the
same entrance, where Ethan is happy to notice that
the corpse of his future self has gone. He rushes
to take a look at the world outside, and feels
relieved to see a futuristic eco-friendly city,
in contrast to the deserted one from earlier. His
decision had changed the future of mankind.
Subscribe for more videos like this,
turn on notifications, and leave a like
to help the channel out.
Thank you for watching.